jetzt steht es fest dem bau des größten
radioteleskops der welt steht nichts
mehr im weg ein entsprechendes abkommen
wurde im märz unterzeichnet das squaire
kilometer er soll laut plan aus
tausenden antennen in afrika und
australien bestehen die per
glasfaserkabel vernetzt sind spätestens
2030 soll das mega teleskop an den start
gehen und hundert mal empfindlicher sein
als jedes andere derzeit aktive
radioteleskop und auch die ziele des
projekts sind wirklich mehr als
ehrgeizig unter anderem soll ein 3d
weltraum atlas erstellt werden der uns
einen blick in das frühe universum
ermöglichen könnte auch der dunklen
energie und außerirdischem leben könnten
wir mit hilfe von square kilometer
endlich auf die spur kommen
alles zu diesem weltweit einzigartigen
projekt geht es bei klicks um science
fiction die gibt es täglich
faszinierendes 1 videos abonniert den
kanal nur dann verpasst er nichts
herzlich willkommen das ist wirklich
eine entscheidung die die astrophysik
weltweit nach vorne bringen wird das
projekt squaire kilometer rsk soll
nämlich nicht weniger als die weltweit
größte wissenschaftseinrichtung werden
seine infrastruktur soll sich über drei
kontinente auf der nord- und
südhalbkugel erstrecken sein
hauptquartier hat die einrichtung in
großbritannien tausende einzel antennen
und hunderte von parabolspiegeln bilden
zwei beobachtungsnetz werke die sich
über hunderte kilometer in südafrika und
australien erstrecken
die gebaute antennen fläche des mega
teleskop soll dann eine million
quadratmeter betragen und eine
schnellere durchmusterung des himmels
möglich machen als je zuvor heraus kommt
dabei nicht nur eine 50 mal höhere
auflösung als die bildauflösung des
hubble-weltraumteleskops sondern zudem
auch eine unvorstellbare menge an
beobachtungsdaten die verarbeitet werden
muss das werden nur die schnellsten
supercomputer der welt schaffen
feststeht
rund 600 petabyte sollen pro jahr
gespeichert werden das entspricht 600
milliarden baht also der
speicherkapazität von mehr als einer
halben million laptops das muss man sich
mal vorstellen diese unvorstellbar große
datenmenge wird dann zur auswertung an
die wissenschaftsgemeinde verteilt
jedenfalls wurde ende märz
der entscheidende grundstein für das skl
gelegt sieben staaten haben in rom das
abkommen für den bau des weltgrößten
radioteleskops unterzeichnet dabei sind
südafrika portugal die niederlande
italien china australien und
großbritannien täterin cesar ski die
vorsitzende des skf und sagt zu dem
unterzeichneten abkommen rom wurde auch
nicht an einem tag erbaut entsprechend
werden der entwurf der aufbau
ausschließlich der betrieb des größten
teleskops der erde jahrzehntelange
anstrengungen sachkenntnis innovation
durchhaltevermögen und globale
zusammenarbeit erfordern
heute haben wir den grundstein dafür
gelegt um das skl schließlich
wirklichkeit werden zu lassen
auch indien und schweden wollen sich
beteiligen das steht aber noch nicht
endgültig fest sicher ist jedenfalls
dass deutschland raus ist sehr zum unmut
vieler deutscher forschungsteams und der
wissenschafts community da dass es als
eines der vielversprechendsten
wissenschaftsprojekte überhaupt gilt den
ausstieg aus dem projekt und der
finanzierung hatte die deutsche
bundesregierung im sommer 2014 verkündet
mit fatalen folgen für deutsche
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
der nur wer zahlt darf das mega teleskop
auch nutzen die geplanten
forschungsschwerpunkte des sk
jedenfalls können sich sehen lassen
fachleute sind sich sicher dass sie mit
hilfe des mega teleskop fundamentale
wissenslücken in der physik endlich
schließen können denn kosmische
radiowellen entstehen bei vielen
natürlichen prozessen beispielsweise
werden sie von gaswolken im all aus
gesendet sie haben eine deutlich größere
wellenlänge als sichtbares licht nämlich
zwischen zehn zentimetern und 100
kilometern
der vorteil sie werden anders als
röntgenstrahlung oder infrarot licht
nicht von der erdatmosphäre verschluckt
mehrere millionen galaxien sollten mit
hilfe des sg kartiert werden so könnte
dann auch endlich die entwicklung des
universums über milliarden von jahren
zurückverfolgt werden
auch die suche nach leben im universum
wird durch den betrieb des sgl wohl noch
einmal weiter voranschreiten und auch
die relativitätstheorie von einstein
könnte unter extremen bedingungen
getestet werden zudem sind fachleute
optimistisch dass das sk
auch dabei helfen wird endlich der
mysteriösen dunklen energie auf die
schliche zu kommen mehr als 1.000
experten und expertinnen aus 20 ländern
waren bereits in den letzten fünf jahren
an den design arbeitet für das sgl
beteiligt ende 2020 sollen dann verträge
in einer höhe von 700 millionen euro an
anbieter in den mitgliedstaaten gehen
damit dass sgl konstruiert werden kann
auch die deutsche forschungsgemeinschaft
hat weiterhin großes interesse an dem
projekt und plant die gründung des
vereins für datenintensive
radioastronomie dazu stefan wagner von
der universität heidelberg die gesamte
astronomische gemeinde hat schon lange
auf ein radio observatorium mit solch
hervorragende leistungen stärker auf der
südhalbkugel der erde basel die gründung
einer organisation für den aufbau und
den betrieb des observatoriums ist ein
entscheidender schritt vorwärts wir als
astrophysiker in deutschland sind sehr
daran interessiert beim skm mitzumachen
das einblicke ins universum weit über
die derzeit vorhandene möglichkeiten
bieten wird bislang beteiligt sich die
deutsche forschungsgemeinschaft an
vorläufer projekten wie dem mercado
teleskop in südafrika das im sommer 2008
zehn eingeweiht wurde
ob wir dem fuß beim skm noch in die tür
bekommen wir bleiben dran
das berühmteste radiosignal der welt
stammt es von außerirdischen was ist das
warnsignal draufklicken anschauen und
natürlich abonnieren weltraum wissen von
astro comics tv bis dann bleibt dran